the favorite starring Oscar winners Emma
Stone and Rachel Weisz now the ladies
telling me you have never seen a period
film like this I will stop kicking you
it's very intimate between these women
they they slap each other they kiss each
other they make love to each other they
argue with each other they flattery it's
very like women getting to do just about
just about everything there is to do
Emma and Rachel are competitive cousins
vying for the love and affection of
Queen Anne of England played by Olivia
Colman you have become close to Abigail
she is a Viper your Janice Joe Elwynn
Taylor Swift's man plays Emma's husband
and one scene gets pretty steamy we all
wedding night whichever one was kind of
pretty out there it's not PG no no it's
not have you did see anything that she
just had to take care of and you can bet
super Spice Girl fan emma is pumped for
their reunion there was a really night
mint in you to see them reunite yeah
very exciting but how do you feel about
posh not being part of them I'm bummed
oh come on posh she's stopped doing
those cute clothes and get back in the
band I mean or just do both I want to
let her be free
[Music]